شارك بيني جانس رئيس حزب معسكر الدوله
والعضو في مجلس الحرب في مظاهره مساء امس
وسط مدينه تل ابيب للمطالبه باستعاده
الاسرى الاسرائيليين من قطاع غزه وفي حيفا
طالب محتجون باقاله حكومه نتنياهو واجراء
انتخابات جديده واعتبر ممثلون عن عائلات
الاسرى الاسرائيليين ان ملف اعاده ابنائهم
ليس ضمن اولويه الحكومه وتعهد المتظاهرون
بتصعيد الاحتجاج طيله الساعات 24
القادمه معنا من مدينه رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري اهلا وليد جديد
التصريحات والمواقف الاسرائيليه بشان سير
الحرب وكذلك هذا الانقسام وهذه الازمه في
اسرائيل بدايه مع دخول الحرب يومها المئه
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي الليله وفجر هذا
اليوم عن مقتل ضابط وجندي من ما رفع مجمل
عدد قتلاه منذ
بدايه الحرب في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
الى
522 من بينهم 194 ضابطا وجنديا قتلوا منذ
بدايه حربه البريه في قطاع غزه منذ في ال
26 من اكتوبر الماضي وهذه الحرب حاليا
المتواصله قال هيرتس هالبي رئيس هيئه
الاركان العسكريه ان اربعه الويه ما زالت
تشارك فيها بمعنى ان الحرب ضار ومتواصله
بينما قال نتنياهو بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
في طريقه لتحقيق الانتصار على حد تعبيره
وكان بذلك يرد على بعض المنتقدين الذين
يقولون ان اسرائيل ستخرج مهزومه من هذه
الحرب رغم كل ما فعلتهم هذا على الصعيد
الميداني لكن على الصعيد السياسي الداخلي
واضح ان هناك توتر عالي وصل سجل ذروه
جديده الليله الماضيه خلال اجتماع مجلس
الحرب حيث منع نتنياهو مدير مكتب وزير
الدفاع من حضور الجلسه وهو ما اغضب يواف
جلنت وزير الدفاع الذي خرج من الجلسه
غاضبا وغاب عنها لنحو ساعه وهي خطوه غير
مسبوقه في تاريخ دائره صنع القرار في
اسرائيل خاصه خلال فترات الحرب لكن هذا
ياتي امتدادا ايضا لما كان عليه الحال في
اجتماعي الطاقم الوزاري الامن السياسي
المصغر يوم الاربعاء الماضي والمعروف
بالكابينه حيث جهه جلنت من قبل وزراء
مقربين من نتنياهو بالاستخفاف والاستهتار
بينهم
وزيره المواصلات ميري ريجف وكذلك الوزير
ام سالم ميري ريجف عند وصول جلنت بدات
بتوزيع الفشار البوب كورن وقالت لمن حولها
ل قد بدات المسرحيه او العرض بينما ام
سالم كان قد هاجم الوزير في مجلس الحرب
جانس وا في خلال الجلسه التفسير الموجود
لدى كثيرين هو ان هذان الوزيران على وجه
الخصوص ما كانان ليجران على القيام بمثل
هذه التصرفات لو لم يكن لديهم ايعاز او
ضوء اخضر من رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو هذا
يكشف حاله الانقسام الموجوده والتي تمتد
سواء حول مسار الحرب او ما يتعلق بقضيه
الاسرائيليين الاسرى والمحتجزين في قطاع
غزه وهذا ما دفع ايضا جانس الى الى المش ر
كتي قبل ذلك في المظاهره الكبيره التي
شارك فيها نحو 100 ال من الاسرائيليين الى
جانب ذوي المحتجزين في غزه والتي جرت في
تل ابيب تحديدا فيما بات يعرف اسرائيليا ب
ميدان المختطفين او في منطقه وزاره الدفاع
او الكرياه وهي مجمع قياده الجيش والاجهزه
الامنيه ورئاسه الوزراء والمعروفه بالكر
ومنها يتم اداره هذه الحرب وكل الحروب
السابقه كل ذلك عكس حاله التوتر وانعدام
الثقه سواء داخل دائره صنع القرار في
اسرائيل او على مستوى الشارع تجاه قيادته
السياسيه وكانت هناك مظاهرت اخرتان غير
مظاهره تل ابيب التان رفعتا خاصه في حيفا
التي رفعت شعارات تطالب باقاله نتنياهو
وحكومته يضاف الى هذا
كله العريضه التي كان قد وقع عليها
171 من كبار جنرالات وقاده الجيش السابقين
وقاده الاجهزه الامنيه هؤلاء وقعوا على
عريضه في اليومين الماضيين تطالب باجراء
انتخابات اسرائيليه واسقاط هذه الحكومه
اليمينيه المتطرفه واقامه حكومه بديله
منها تكون قادره على التعامل مع الوضع
بشكل افضل نتنياهو من ناحيته متهم من قبل
سواء المراقبين في اسرائيل او من قبل
معارضيه وجزء حتى من حلفائه بان كل
تصرفاته وقراراته مبنيه على خدمه مكاسب
سياسيه داخليه بحته اي انه يتصرف بذعر من
الوزيرين المتطرفين العنصريين سموتريتش
وبين كفير ويخشى من ان ينسحب من حكومته
وبالتالي يفقد هذا الائتلاف وتسقط حكومته
قبل نهايه الحرب او مع نهايتها وان كل ما
يفعله محاوله تثبيت هذه التوليفه اليمينيه
المتطرفه كي يستمر في رئاسه الوزراء الى
اطول فتره ممكنه هذه الاوض ضع في مجملها
يرى كثيرون انها تؤثر حتى على صناعه
القرار العسكري وعلى الجيش في هذه الحرب
التي توصف بانها اسرائيليا بانها ضاريه
ومعقده ومركبه وليست بالسهل وهالي رئيس
الاركان كان قد اشار ايضا امس الى ان
الحرب ستستغرق لمده طويله وهي اشاره الى
انه مع دخول الحرب يومها المئه حتى هذه
الساعه الجيش الاسرائيلي العرمرم ورغم كل
القو قه التي الغاشمه التي يستخدمها لكنه
لم يسجل بعد تقدما استراتيجيا نحو الاهداف
التي كان قد اعلنها من قبل هذه الاهداف
عاد نتنياهو بالامس في محاوله كما يبدو
لدغدغة
لم يعودوا يثقون بكل هذه الاقوال بعد يوم
بعد مئه يوم من هذه الحرب المتواصله